it meant everything to us like you get
in the belts and then you hey everybody
welcome to another episode of hot box
and I'm Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson
Mike we've got a crew are today the
wrong [ __ ] going down with just a legend
Noriega in the house oh man I'm so happy
one love but forget again three in the
morning I get it no I get up at 2:00 in
the morning I go downstairs I listened
to some Ella Fitzgerald smoked up some
it didn't throw him I go into around
three o'clock I going to my bike I went
to the bike for hours and I come stood
and I walk through the treatment for
hour and we're gonna do the treadmill
the bike I had my headphones up when I
go upstairs
I just the treadmill and they said my
toes in the pool and I put the one loved
one that's why I start walking through
fire remix remix one love thank you game
for having me a part of the one love
real estate man that's great Ricky yo
but Mike man let me tell you something
man I watch a podcast but yeah thank you
but yours too I'm a big fan of it and
you're fluent something like smoking
that way I started smoking I wanted
[Applause]
so you're always feeling good-looking
night are my I thought people want to
see if that our better so let's let's
get straight into it go for it in my
podcast there's a famous story right
with the locks the locks was walking
through on a red carpet and they said
that you walk through by yourself
probably yeah and you asked Eve [ __ ] you
tonight there's not any time this is not
me - yes for you free me to go with the
lockers I thought she could drain was
dead - dr. Dre yeah I was just living my
life back then my god me friends the
good close friends them close race oh
yeah I'ma be honest I sinned man I'm
yeah I'm taking over
no it's all good but I'll be honest man
do you even know what you meant for New
York City man huh like like yeah when we
went out of town yeah when we went out
of town for New York City I'm just
because I've seen Jim Jones on here and
I seen when he said when you walk
through the tunnel by the way which is
the most horrific club ever at this time
and we're Michael walk through Michael
walk through by itself just I'm a
cosigner with Jim Jones said jury on and
everyone just move on but let me get to
the point the point I'm trying to say is
do you understand like New York City
like it was it was the proudest we've
ever been man let me tell you something
okay
listen I can remember being 1 1976 back
I remember being on 42nd Street
snatching people's change me snatch
their Wireless ripped their pockets out
I'll snatch something off the stand they
some clothes or something and I was just
a regular lal miah of the regularly so
and every now and then some of those
Spanish guys are just see me an ace must
have saw me rob some
their customers the week before and they
may start throwing stuff you
[ __ ]
and such don't get that [ __ ] watch
that mother for either TV starts talking
loud mm on top of his voice in the whole
name is this Steven [ __ ] watch
that little black bastard you know and
it comes from listen I come ten years so
it's 1986 now those same people that
they're giving me free Tufts taking
pictures with me now same stuff to try
to kick me in my ass and I used to come
by now to make pitches kissing on me and
everything taking pictures with their
babies now what do you stand with Don
King huh what happened Don listen I'm
cool with Donald King are you passionate
or you know I know
what's your smoking dirty box and not
listen in a way I know I used to smoke
doing my amateur days right and then um
I didn't make it to the Olympic truck so
I [ __ ] got massive offense because of
this weed that's why I didn't make it to
the Olympics so I stopped smoking weed
from like 84 mmm
to [ __ ] like 97 yeah I wanted to be
champion mmm Wanda mean in my life yeah
you know yeah I wanted my mother to be
proud of she had died I wanted them to
be proud of me Oh someone to beat em you
know that at that age you don't know you
think being coming rich and famous it's
the essence of life because that's what
TV makes you believe when you're a young
kid but you know they just company it
compounds your problems
yeah hey but like hey but no Mike
selling it maybe I know my team ready to
blow up what do you thinks gonna happen
as depends on me how I handle the
situation and then pass the test the
first time at a lot of money but this
time is going to be different
I'm sorry yeah you know we need y'all on
drink chance right definitely definitely
we want to start to start this what did
you do what Oh like you know process
yes podcast yet the other one do can we
I don't like hearing my [ __ ] voice
[ __ ] so I did so we did the podcast one
day and then the [ __ ] can I get some the
ratings went off the roof and so um I
wonder what are we doing what's you
surprised of course you knew the radius
was gonna go up - yeah let me ask you
you were not surprised
well I'm surprised because I I know oh
yeah I mean I think you know Mike Mike
is a guy who I've learned he really just
goes where the universe takes him you
know and really learns a lot as he goes
and he was really into podcasts I mean
podcasts with a wave of the future
yes on it means business as far as
communication and entertainment in
Phillips you know I came here broken
with a habit yeah cleaned up yeah when
you say junky what you mean junkie like
cocaine okay okay what's really cool is
that this podcast from start to finish
well we're not done yet but you know
it's really been a watching Mike on his
journey to self and procedure 101 master
what made you do the one man stand I'm
sorry I'm taking over because you know
what when I heard of it I didn't see it
but when I saw it I was like this is
genius
yeah I saw um Chad's commentary the guy
who did um what's that thinking wrong
still a Bronx Tale so he did it on stage
instead he did on stage and I told my
wife baby I couldn't do that hmm I said
it's like me Europe but you're asking me
question I won't let him actually
question I do like mr. Parmenter II do
from an actor point of view
yeah Eddie Mike is amazing you know I
would've never thought that no [ __ ]
me up who got my credit card who got the
wine cuz we're going in let me just tell
you something man I watch up I watch our
podcast i watch you are which you guys
do and i want to congratulate you guys
to your face because biggest thing is no
one could do what y'all do and how y'all
doing I love it like I sincerely love it
I sit back and I watch it and I really
love what you guys are doing so I want
to say it to your face I didn't say no
because I said it on Twitter and I set
it on Instagram before but you know um
you know we're gonna take our coaching
this is what's happening in the world
we're gonna take our culture and this is
the first step because every time a
boxer should announce a fight they
should be here yeah yeah I was talking
to UM that's what we should do we should
promote people fighting like llama
chenko and David yes one more take off
should be here yes yeah how you feel
about llamas leave the [ __ ] bad you
think you yeah because he because he is
having low losses right now no but
listen he only has nine 512 fight sounds
like he's under 20 no but he got 500
amateur fights okay this is amateur mean
that much
yeah know what know what means a lot
okay I'm repetition the right you do it
the more you do it
you see when he fight he's almost doing
it with his eyes closed you see no one
no one ever gave him no one ever won
around only one guy wondering I think
this guy dropped and he's only got
everyone around but he guy he came up
and knocked the guy out cold with a body
punch but I don't think I'd ever be one
around cuz he dropped them but other
than that he's he's never lost a round
beside that one fight smoke Brownville
blunts take one hit take one hit cuz you
gotta say you gotta take a brown girl
let me tell you something
I used to probably goes in Brownsville
with my Brownsville cousins it was
horrible you know you know it's crazy
but Brownsville cousins boss man is
cousins by the way I went and we robbed
a [ __ ] in a barber shop it's hard it's
hard because the guy was getting the
shape-up came to get me Bobby shot one
day no I'm sorry my man bothers but I'm
in there with this crackhead came in it
I said listen it might buy me a haircut
okay I bought your haircut if you let me
call you Mike Mike yeah Mike will you
buy me a hit that's a yeah I'll buy you
a haircut but you gotta let me cut it
for the [ __ ] and so I'm trying to cut
his hair I learn and the barber oldest
up my messes nah but you got the light
this [ __ ] [ __ ] came in
then a guy grabbed the gun and pushed
him back and he kicked the gun he put me
a boom boom he just kept bugged or
blowing the [ __ ] to close it up I
said what's that [ __ ] but then again
right the [ __ ] that was in
there
what stick-up kids I think he was coming
to get dumb oh wow stick-up kid is
coming to get this stick-up kid yeah
that's all yeah listen do you know my
man screw from Jersey City yes I know
I've definitely was not there yeah that
was Capone yeah no I was not there we
took a loss yeah damn that was
definitely that was definitely a pick up
to school and bit at the bar or you
because they are you know I'm Latino so
they always come see me and they get us
get me confused but that was definitely
components definitely I can't believe
you smoking a blunt
no but might let me let me ask you a
question this is a president because I
still go to Branson a lot yeah and I
found the time of Branson this there was
a altercation that happened with you and
Mitch green dabba doo
yeah yeah you know Mitch green just a
drunk junkie [ __ ] is coming at talkin
shy liking me but he was just being
disrespectful
oh oh yes yes have to get he for
Brooklyn to need some Queens Oh No Madhu
Mitchell do this Mitchell um he was
outside I full of himself did you do
this he'll go to the gas station right
and to give me the [ __ ] money a child
robbed a gas station attendant so the
gas station he tell you starting I got
no money so get you a time up and
[ __ ] stop pumping gas
that's insane so what happens to yah yah
that be dead cuz that be dead it's not
4:00 in the morning uh-huh I came back
from these heels you know was um you
know when they had the college time in
Howard you have a whole cup yes I came
back at them to pick up my clothes from
dapper Africans always in that work at
night and sometimes it's my chicks in
there and Ford the morning yeah big time
you'd be surprised and so I went there
so everybody and then I'm talking
everybody laughing Walter Perry was
there too and right and I was laughing
right and next time when he could
everybody stop laughing and for the
record how tall are you 510
okay till half but listen you're
installing [ __ ] me up that's where you
ain't beat me that's what [ __ ] I
was gonna give him some money came in
here for some money I was gonna get my G
I was looking my G but he said some
Farley started talking some gangster
[ __ ] like keep dissociation said yes
shoulda said it so yeah yeah well you so
happen
I'm so happy right now you know what I
get to hit a story yeah first I read it
in the papers and I was like oh well
last night we've is this hotbox on live
and somebody said did you know Mitch
green as a preacher now get the [ __ ] out
of believe in [ __ ] that's what somebody
said they said Mike if that's true you
guys sure hell yeah well I'm looking
this up how what made you get into hut
in the podcast yeah best [ __ ] vodka
you have the [ __ ] real live homeboy
yeah killer drinking [ __ ] well thank you
thank you but what happened was I
watched what is it TNT Charles Barkley
and yak in these guys and I said
although I disagree with their opinion I
can see that these guys come from the
culture they come from the game so I
said where's our [ __ ]
you know I'm saying like like in my
opinion I think every boxer in the world
from Earl Spence to Floyd Mayweather
should be sitting here in my opinion if
they don't smoke that's okay that's cool
too that's kinda like what but the thing
about it is there's no one in the
universe that can't say we don't know
Mike no no hear me out
him yeah because I know you humble I
watch him I watch this [ __ ] I know yeah
but let me let me big you up for you
okay I'll take that but um Earl Spence
and I forget who he just fought Porter
Laura Earl Spencer important should have
been here it shouldn't be moment here as
opposed to ESPN and TNT and that's good
it's good because that's the people
that's paying the check but at the end
of the day
when you have your own support in your
own they should come to you and that's
that I would rather I would rather watch
the next fight
whether it's Manny Pacquiao verse Danny
Garcia I rather watch that being
promoted on here I respect that listen
that's awesome to know what I would love
to have them on but the line is too
[ __ ] long no III want to stop you the
line is not long when it comes to Mike
Tyson oh my bad my bad my bad
oh look dude there's a video my credit
card tubas diminish Green has turned
Christian Mike can we film this and I
will go to the church with you I will go
to the church with you me you they got
him on a pope wait now is he talking
what is he thinking I wish I I don't
think we have our setup right now
Capaldi please shame that I left in my
past could I really be new and I was
total custody you don't have to be a
drug anything you don't have to be an
alcoholic
you can be new for treat camp session we
need to go to history beautiful yeah
hell yeah dude but do you really know
how much you mean in New York City like
I will be so proud to walk through any
neighborhood now you know what I'm be
honest with you that might have been the
realest [ __ ] I ever heard because that's
exactly what New York is like a billion
now is that what that's all you got
that's all I'm not Phil you didn't ever
even touch the tip of the [ __ ] beak
[Music]
me take something I'll tell you one I'll
tell you one thing like I was in Miami
for like a year and a half and I came
back to New York
violet and my [ __ ] was looking at me
like why you smiling
they don't want like you're smiling but
listen any time I go to Miami I have a
habit of a venereal disease the energy
there is really seductive isn't it no I
know nothing I'm done with this book
doesn't matter they're [ __ ] Columbia
basically why are you [ __ ] I'm just
[ __ ] the life is crazy
I put the cube up if you've been to Cuba
no my wife trying to get me to go to
Cuba but I've never been it's easy to
get there now I wonder you couldn't go
about what to keep [ __ ] cuz Trump let
[ __ ] go to Cuba right yeah but I went
there we wasn't cool the goal is I want
the Cure to go to to make I went to
Jamaica to go to keep one another
it means Fidel did you know I understand
what do you say he went the cube would
Accord
[Music]